This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的学问》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做，听听如何吸取。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
以艰难的方式，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一个骗局。你曾多次篡改过这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。这需要一支网络侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即英文中的 TWO percent，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, my lovely listeners, new and old. Wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode.
相信你的闺蜜。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜，相信我》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，我可爱的新老听众们。无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目。
I hope you've been well. I hope you've been treating yourself nicely, pursuing something positive and exciting in your life. I've been chugging along. I'm in the planning stages for some pretty fun. projects coming out soon that I am super excited to show with you all. I feel like some of you have already figured it out, but a little spoiler if you're a big journaler or note taker, I feel like you'll be pretty pumped for what's coming, which I realize is actually literally a dead giveaway,
希望你们一切都好。希望你们一直对自己很好，在生活中追求一些积极且令人兴奋的事情。我也一直在稳步前行。我正在筹备一些非常有趣的项目，这些项目很快就会推出，我超级兴奋能向大家展示。我觉得你们中的一些人已经猜到了，但如果你是一个喜欢写日记或做笔记的人，一个小小的剧透是，我觉得你会对即将到来的一切感到非常兴奋，我意识到这其实算是一个彻头彻尾的剧透，
but you know what, I can't keep a secret. So there you go. There are so much in the works at the moment and just taking a little moment to say I'm so grateful for all the support you guys have shown me recently. In every capacity, the show is, you know, reaching so many new people. There are so many exciting projects in the works that wouldn't be possible without such amazing loyal listeners. So starting with a quick shout out to you guys who make this possible. But let's get into what we're actually talking about today. Okay. So we're doing a pretty science heavy episode. One I am fascinated by, one I have wanted to do. for ages. And today we're finally getting around to an old-fashioned deep dive, a big deep dive into
但你知道吗，我藏不住秘密。所以就这样吧。目前有很多工作正在筹划中，借此机会表达我对大家最近给予的所有支持的无比感激。在各个方面，节目都在，你知道的，触及了如此多新的人群。有很多激动人心的项目正在进行中，如果没有如此令人惊叹的忠实听众，这一切都是不可能实现的。所以，首先要向让这一切成为可能的你们致以由衷的谢意。但让我们进入今天真正要讨论的话题吧。好的。所以我们要聊一期偏向科学的节目。这是一期让我着迷、我一直想做的节目。
sleep. How often do we really think about sleep, to be honest, other than that it's this like eight hour, seven hour black hole in our days that we know we need, that we never feel like we have enough of unless you're one of those insane people who can sleep for five hours. We are told that we should take magnesium if we want to sleep well, that we should have a silk eye mask. a nighttime routine, that melatonin is the key to rest, that we need to listen to the people who say to wake up at 5 a.m. Don't use our phones before bed, lucid dream. You know, the world has a lot to say about sleep because it is really how we spend a third of our lives. And it has become a huge wellness topic for sure. But how much do we actually know? You and I, the average person,
很久了。今天我们终于要开始深入探讨一个老生常谈的话题了，那就是——睡眠。说实话，除了知道它是我们生活中的那个持续八小时、七小时的黑洞，是我们知道自己需要、却又总觉得永远不够的东西（除非你是那种每天睡五个小时也精神矍铄的怪胎之外），我们平时到底有多常去思考睡眠？我们被告知，如果想睡个好觉就该吃镁，应该用真丝眼罩。
how much trivia would we have in our back pockets to do with sleep? For something so vital and genuinely life-giving, we're going to talk about that in a second. Sleep is seen as rather boring. You know, that's the whole cliche to be like a snooze, to be a bore, to be like falling asleep at your desk, at work. You know, I think that sleep, I don't know, not to say it gets a bad reputation, but I don't think we think about it enough.
有一个晚间例行程序，褪黑素是休息的关键，我们应该听从那些建议早上5点起床的人的话，睡前不要玩手机，进行清明梦。你知道的，关于睡眠，世人有很多看法，因为睡眠确实占去了我们三分之一的人生。它绝对已经成了一个巨大的健康热门话题。但我们实际上了解多少呢？你和我，作为普通人，
why do we really care about the moments we're unconscious? That's the biggest reasons. You know, nothing's really happening in those hours. We literally can't remember anything other than our dreams, sometimes not even those. So it seems rather insignificant. Obviously, I don't believe that at all. I think that sleep is so misunderstood. And really, it is the key to unlocking a lot about our life, about the fatigue that we experience, the motivational deficits we see in other areas of our lives. It's even linked to being a more kind person, a less irritable person, and a myriad of health outcomes. You may not even notice that you are functioning at less than 100% as a direct result of poor sleep, especially in our 20s when there is this whole culture, or I would say expectation around sacrificing sleep
我们脑子里到底有多少关于睡眠的冷知识呢？对于这样一件至关重要且真正赋予生命的事物，我们一会儿再谈。睡眠被认为相当枯燥。你知道的，那种经典的说法，把无聊叫做“打瞌睡”（snooze），把厌烦叫做犯困，就像在工作时趴在桌子上睡着一样。你知道的，我认为睡眠，我不知道，并不是说它名声不好，但我认为我们对它的思考远远不够。
and either overworking, pushing ourselves to burnout, or trying to keep up with a big social schedule or social expectations trying to do all the fun things that can't fit into our daytime hours and pushing off sleep, hitting snooze as many times as possible. I'm not going to come out and say that that is a bad thing to do, that you need to get your eight hours, otherwise your world is going to fall apart. More so, just I want to explore how we can maximize good rest. The hidden world to do with sleep is so fascinating. So we're going to talk about why we need sleep. What happens in your brain as you fall asleep? The myth of the Russian sleep experiment.
为什么我们要真正在意我们无意识的时刻？这就是最大的原因。你知道的，在那些小时里真的没有发生什么。除了我们的梦之外，我们字面意义上什么也记不住，有时甚至连梦也记不住。所以它看起来相当微不足道。当然，我完全不这么认为。我认为睡眠被严重误解了。实际上，它是解开我们生活很多谜题的关键，比如我们感受到的疲劳，我们在生活其他领域看到的动力不足。它甚至与成为一个更善良的人、一个脾气不那么暴躁的人以及无数的健康结果息息相关。你甚至可能没有注意到，由于睡眠不足的直接影响，你的机能正在以低于100%的状态运转，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候，周围充斥着这样一种文化，或者说可以称之为一种期待，那就是牺牲睡眠，
I've wanted to talk about this for ages. And then some more kind of nuanced topics. Sleep as a form of self-sabotage. The concept of sleep debt and sleep hygiene. So much to be said about this topic, I think without further ado, let's get into it. Okay. First off, let's cover our basics. what actually happens in our brains and in our bodies when we fall asleep.
要么过度工作，把自己逼到筋疲力尽，要么试图跟上繁忙的社交日程或社交期望，试图做完所有白天塞不下的趣事，从而不断推迟睡眠，能按多少次贪睡按钮就按多少次。我不会直接跳出来说这是一件坏事，说你必须睡满八小时，否则你的世界就会崩塌。我更多地只是想探讨我们如何才能最大限度地享受高质量的休息。与睡眠相关的隐藏世界是如此迷人。所以我们将讨论为什么我们需要睡眠。当你入睡时，你的大脑会发生什么？俄罗斯睡眠实验的迷思。
I think we all hear about hitting our REM cycle. That's been everywhere recently, and that's only one part of it. Actually, when we fall asleep, when we are actively asleep, we can divide this state of mind into four stages. Three of those stages count as non-rapid eye movement sleep or stages, NRE for short. And then we have REM sleep, which stands for rapid eye movement sleep. I don't think a lot of us know that that's what REM actually stands for and it is as it describes. During this stage of sleep, our brain activity, our breathing, our heart rate, our blood pressure, almost
我一直想聊这个话题很久了。然后是一些更微妙的话题。把睡眠作为一种自我破坏的形式。睡眠债务和睡眠卫生的概念。关于这个话题有太多要说的了，我想闲话少说，我们直接切入正题吧。好的。首先，让我们了解一下基础知识。当我们入睡时，我们的大脑和身体究竟发生了什么？
match what they would look like when we are awake, but we're not. And they all increase. We become almost temporarily paralyzed, unable to move our arms. or legs. It is not the most restful kind of sleep, which is another big myth. And it usually occurs about 90 minutes after you fall asleep. So it's almost at the end of a sleep cycle. So a sleep cycle is where you go from being awake through all the non-rapid eye movement stages of sleep. And then you end up in REM sleep. And that's where we often get the most intense dreams because we have the most brain activity going on. And it's during that stage that a lot of scientists and researchers believe that we process our emotions, we form memories.
我想我们都听说过进入快速眼动（REM）周期。这个概念最近到处都是，但这只是其中一部分。事实上，当我们入睡时，当我们处于活跃的睡眠状态时，我们可以将这种精神状态分为四个阶段。其中三个阶段被称为非快速眼动睡眠或非快速眼动睡眠阶段，简称 NREM。然后我们有 REM 睡眠，代表快速眼动睡眠。我想很多人并不知道 REM 实际代表什么，它正如其所描述的那样。在这个睡眠阶段，我们的大脑活动、呼吸、心率、血压，几乎
If you want to learn about why it is that we dream in particular, especially in REM sleep, we actually have a whole episode on that called The Psychology of Dreams. It's one of my favorite episodes ever. But most people assume that dreams are a product of memory formation and processing all of the thoughts, feelings, experiences, flashbacks that we haven't worked through during the day. We still aren't completely sure why some people have more vivid or memorable dreams than others, because it's so hard to measure something that we can't always remember.
与我们醒着时的情况相匹配，但我们并没有醒。而且它们都会增加。我们变得几乎是暂时性瘫痪，无法移动手臂或双腿。这不是最让人恢复精力的睡眠，这也是另一个巨大的误区，它通常发生在你入睡大约90分钟后。所以它几乎处于一个睡眠周期的末尾。因此，睡眠周期是指你从清醒状态经历所有的非快速眼动睡眠阶段。然后你最终进入 REM 睡眠。正是在那里，我们经常能得到最生动的梦境，因为我们拥有最多的大脑活动。正是在这个阶段，许多科学家和研究人员认为我们处理情绪、形成记忆。
But some factors include having a greater imagination, also medications, sleep disruptions, like if you are woken up during REM sleep, you'll probably have a greater recall of your dreams. And then things like stress and trauma, even grief, make us very vivid dreamers. We have a lot going on emotionally and mentally during our waking hours within our lives. And we can't, we don't, always have the brain space to deal with that, to find a place for those memories and those experiences in our brain. So it's when we are asleep that our mind kind of gets to work filtering through all of that and voila.
如果你想了解为什么我们会做梦，尤其是在 REM 睡眠中，我们其实有一整集专门探讨这个的节目，叫做《梦的心理学》（The Psychology of Dreams）。这是我最喜欢的节目之一。但大多数人认为梦是记忆形成以及处理所有我们在白天没有解决的想法、感觉、经历、闪回的产物。我们仍然不完全确定为什么有些人比其他人有更生动或更容易记住的梦，因为要衡量我们并不总能记住的东西实在太难了。
That is why we dream. Okay, so we're kind of starting back to front here because REM sleep, as I said, is actually the last stage of sleep. And it occurs after we pass through what we now know as N-R-M-E sleep. So we have three stages. We have N-1 sleep. This is the transition between wakefulness and sleeping. It's characterized by slowed eye movement. reduce muscle activity, our heart rate is dropping.
但一些影响因素包括拥有更丰富的想象力、药物、睡眠干扰（比如如果你在 REM 睡眠期间被吵醒，你可能会对梦有更深刻的回忆）。然后像压力和创伤，甚至悲伤，都会让我们成为非常生动的做梦者。在清醒的时候，我们的生活在情感和精神上有太多的事情要处理。我们无法、也没有总是足够的脑力去处理这些，去在我们的大脑中为这些记忆和经历找到一个安放之处。所以，正是在我们入睡时，我们的大脑开始工作，过滤所有这些，然后瞧。
Then we get to N2 sleep. There's a further decline in brain activity, temperature, heart rate, all the things that indicate wakefulness. And then we have N3 sleep. So this is also known as deep sleep. And this is where our body really undergoes a lot of the restorative processes for fixing up everything that's happened within our mind and our bodies during the day. So then three sleep, the one we just spoke about, that is deep sleep.
这就是我们做梦的原因。好的，所以我们有点像是在倒叙，因为正如我所说，REM 睡眠实际上是睡眠的最后一个阶段。它发生在我们经历现在所知的 N-R-M-E 睡眠之后。所以我们有三个阶段。我们有 N1 睡眠。这是清醒与睡眠之间的过渡。其特点是眼球运动减慢。肌肉活动减少，我们的心率下降。
As we fall asleep, our brain actually remains quite active, even in that final stage. Processing information, consolidating memories, keeping us breathing, areas like our amygdala and our hippocampus, they show the most amount of activity and they are the parts of our brain that help in the creation and storage of episodic memories. but they also tend to help with core functions, like ensuring we are still alive even though we are unconscious. So let's talk about why we need sleep. Wouldn't it be great if we could be operating at all hours of the day? Imagine how productive we would be,
然后我们进入 N2 睡眠。大脑活动、体温、心率以及所有表明清醒状态的指标都在进一步下降。然后我们有 N3 睡眠。这也称为深睡眠。正是在这里，我们的身体真正经历了大量的恢复过程，以修复白天在我们的身心中发生的一切。所以 N3 睡眠，我们刚才谈到的那个，就是深睡眠。
how much more of the world could be explored, how many more stories we would have to tell. It is a nice fantasy, but it is also not how the human body works. because our body and our mind need a break. There is not an endless energy reserve that we can infinitely pull from. Sleep as a biological necessity is still kind of a mystery. And for something that every single creature does, it's interesting because we don't really
当我们入睡时，我们的大脑实际上保持相当活跃，甚至在最后一个阶段也是如此。处理信息、巩固记忆、维持呼吸，像我们的杏仁核和海马体这样的区域，它们表现出最大量的活动，它们是我们大脑中协助创建和存储情景记忆的部分。但它们也倾向于协助核心功能，比如确保我们尽管失去了知觉但仍然活着。那么让我们来谈谈为什么我们需要睡眠。如果我们能在一天中的所有时间都保持运转，那该多好啊。想象一下我们会多么高产，
have a consensus as to why we need it. There are a few theories floating around. Let's talk about them. The first one is the energy conservation theory. So this theory suggests that the main purpose of a good night's sleep is to reduce our energy use during the times of the day, the nighttime, when it would have been inconvenient and less efficient to hunt for food. We need to shut down at some point in the day to save energy for when we are awake. And because our brain is the biggest use of energy in our body, turning it off for a set period of the day saves us a lot of calories. It doesn't mean that sleeping less burns more calories.
我们可以探索更多的世界，我们可以讲述更多的故事。这是一个美好的幻想，但它也不是人体运作的方式。因为我们的身体和大脑需要休息。并没有一个无穷无尽的能量储备可以让我们无限提取。睡眠作为一种生物学上的必需品，仍然是一个谜。对于每一个生物都会做的事情来说，这很有趣，因为我们真的
In fact, you're more likely to hold on to calories if you are not sleeping enough because essentially what happens is your metabolism slows down and says, hey, wait, we're used to having this whole shutdown period where the brain is doing nothing and we can just kind of do our thing. Now the brain is staying awake. It's using so much more energy. Let's slow down how we use calories, how we use fat, how we use glucose, whatever energy store it's pulling from because we're going to need more of that because the brain
没有就为什么我们需要它达成共识。有一些理论在流传。让我们来谈谈它们。第一个是能量节约理论。所以这个理论表明，睡个好觉的主要目的是减少我们在一天中（即夜间）能量的使用，因为在夜间寻找食物是不便且效率低下的。我们需要在一天中的某个时刻关闭系统，为我们醒着的时候节省能量。由于我们的大脑是我们身体中能量消耗最大的部分，在一天中的固定时间将其关闭可以为我们节省大量的热量。这并不意味着睡得少会消耗更多热量。
doesn't want to go anywhere. The brain doesn't want to shut off. So that's the energy restoration theory. Basically, we conserve energy by not using our brain or hours of the day. The other theory is cellular restoration theory, which is the one I believe most in, I would say, although I'm sure it's a combination. The cellular restoration theory says that our body needs sleep in order to repair and regrow cells throughout the body that have been exhausted or stretched during the day. It kind of also relates to brain plasticity as well. And there's a theory around that brain plasticity theory which says that sleep occurs primarily for our brains to reorganize our neurons and our nerve cells.
事实上，如果你睡眠不足，你更有可能保留热量，因为基本上发生的情况是你的新陈代谢减慢了，并且说：“嘿，等等，我们习惯了拥有这样一个整个关闭期，在这个时期大脑什么也不做，我们可以顺其自然地做我们自己的事。现在大脑保持清醒。它消耗了更多的能量。让我们放慢我们使用热量、使用脂肪、使用葡萄糖的方式，无论它提取的是什么能量储备，因为我们需要更多这样的能量，因为大脑
When you sleep, your brain's waste clearance system is well at work there, clearing out waste from the central nervous system and making sure that everything is like almost doing like a deep clean, like doing like a refresh before we wake up for the next day. It's getting rid of all of the excess glucose, cortisol neurotransmitters that haven't been reabsorbed, which build up throughout the day so we can wake up with a clean slate and do it all over again. So research suggests that sleep contributes to memory function as well by converting short-term memory. into long-term memories. Now this is a process that we call memory consolidation. It's not just about making new memories, but also clearing out, erasing unneeded information that might otherwise take up
不想去任何地方。大脑不想关闭。”这就是能量恢复理论。基本上，我们在一天中的某些小时不使用大脑来节约能量。另一个理论是细胞恢复理论，这也是我最相信的一个，虽然我相信它是多种因素的结合。细胞恢复理论认为，我们的身体需要睡眠来修复和重新生长在白天耗尽或拉伸的全身细胞。它在某种程度上也与大脑可塑性有关。围绕大脑可塑性还有一个理论，该理论认为睡眠的发生主要是为了让我们的大脑重新组织我们的神经元和神经细胞。
space in our minds. So the saying and the feeling is that almost all of our memories are consolidated during sleep. I remember being in high school and people saying that if you read your notes right before bed, you would remember them better in the morning. And this kind of like myth is based off of this theory that sleep is where we form long term memories. So if information is processed closer to when we fall asleep, they'll be processed better. Not exactly correct, but really nice try. It's more so that our brain receives a whole lot of information throughout the day, more than it can process, because whilst we are awake, we're also actively filtering through stimuli in our environment, trying to problem solve. So we use sleep.
当你睡觉时，你大脑的废物清除系统正在努力工作，清除中枢神经系统的废物，并确保一切都像是在进行深度清洁，就像在为醒来迎接新的一天做刷新一样。它清除了所有多余的葡萄糖、皮质醇以及未被重新吸收并在白天积聚的神经递质，这样我们就可以带着一张干净的白纸醒来，然后重新开始。因此，研究表明，睡眠还通过将短期记忆转化为长期记忆来促进记忆功能。现在这是一个我们称之为记忆巩固的过程。这不仅关于创造新的记忆，还关于清除、擦除可能在我们的脑海中占用空间的、不需要的信息。
is a basically, you know, as a way to say, okay, enough, let's shut down. We need some time. We need some quiet time to do our memory admin. It's why our memory seems to decline or become a lot more difficult, why we become more forgetful if you haven't been sleeping particularly well. Without sleep, our brain health declines significantly, as does our cognitive and mental and even social functioning during the day. sleep also helps us with emotional regulation.
所以有一种说法和感觉，几乎我们所有的记忆都是在睡眠中得到巩固的。我记得上高中时，人们说如果你在临睡前看笔记，早上会记得更清楚。这种神话般的说法正是基于这样一个理论，即睡眠是我们形成长期记忆的时刻。因此，如果在入睡前不久处理信息，它们会得到更好的处理。这并不完全正确，但真是一个很好的尝试。更准确地说，我们的大脑在白天会接收到大量的信息，超过了它所能处理的极限，因为在我们醒着的时候，我们还在积极地过滤环境中的刺激，试图解决问题。所以我们利用睡眠。
I think we all know that. If you've ever had a really terrible night's sleep and like snapped at somebody, this explains it. It's the same reason why they tell you to sleep on something if you're angry. If you're angry at a partner, at a friend, at a co-worker, whatever it may be, the less sleep you get, the harder it is to control your emotional state. And the more irritable you'll become, the more likely you're going to say things that you don't. main. So let's actually dive into this further. What is going to happen to you and I if we don't get
基本上，你知道的，把它当作一种方式来说：“好了，够了，让我们关机吧。我们需要一些时间。我们需要一些安静的时间来做我们的记忆管理。”这就是为什么如果你一直没有睡好，你的记忆力似乎会下降或变得更加困难，为什么你会变得更加健忘。如果没有睡眠，我们的大脑健康会显著下降，白天我们的认知、精神甚至社交功能也是如此。睡眠还有助于我们进行情绪调节。
enough sleep? Well, a whole range of things. Most importantly, what's going to happen is we're going to find ourselves in sleep debt. Sleep debt is when you sleep fewer hours than your body needs. It's basically it. It's like you overdraw your bank account. You're overdrawing the amount of rest that your body needs to function. Sleep debt is cumulative, meaning that if you regularly get less sleep than you should, you're going to have more sleep debt. Here is the scary thing. So there's an article written by Harvard Health about a recent paper that was published in the current biology journal. And it said that we actually can't recover that debt. We cannot make up our sleep debt for, you know, over a weekend or by sleeping in.
我想我们都知道这一点。如果你曾经有过一个非常糟糕的睡眠并且对某人大发雷霆，这就解释了原因。这也是为什么如果生气了他们会告诉你“睡一觉再说”。如果你对伴侣、朋友、同事或无论什么人生气，你得到的睡眠越少，你就越难控制自己的情绪状态。你就会变得越暴躁，就越有可能说出并非你本意的话。所以让我们深入探讨一下。如果我们得不到足够的睡眠，你我将会发生什么？
because what we have done is disturbed our body's rhythm and given it less than it required. And it's not very forgiving or understanding of that. That's especially hard for people who may suffer from things like insomnia, right? They're constantly in sleep debt. Insomnia is this type of sleep disorder where it's really difficult for people to fall asleep or stay asleep. And obviously it makes sense that people who are experiencing this, not only are they super frustrated because it is a vital human, biological, bodily need to rest. But it means that they are
嗯，会发生一整串事情。最重要的是，将要发生的是我们会发现自己陷入了睡眠债务。睡眠债务就是你睡的时间少于身体所需的量。基本上就是这样。就像你透支了你的银行账户。你透支了身体正常运转所需的休息量。睡眠债务是累积的，这意味着如果你经常得到的睡眠少于你应得的睡眠，你就会背负更多的睡眠债务。可怕的事情在这里。哈佛健康（Harvard Health）上有一篇文章谈到了一篇最近发表在《当代生物学》（Current Biology）杂志上的论文。文章说，我们实际上无法恢复那种债务。我们无法通过周末大睡一场或睡懒觉来弥补我们的睡眠债务。
increasing their emotional sensitivity. They're more likely to experience poorer concentration, irritability. It can even increase our risk factor of things like chronic diseases, like diabetes, like hypertension, like heart disease. I want to go back there and just correct myself. It's not that they're choosing this, right? It's not that they are deliberately increasing their susceptibility. It's just that a failure to sleep has a lot of secondary consequences. It even contributes to hallucinations or an increase in what we call microsleeps. So if you've seen any road safety billboards recently, I think you'll be familiar with this idea whereby our brain can flip very rapidly
因为我们所做的是扰乱了我们身体的节律，给它的比它所需的要少。而它对此并不宽容，也不理解。这对那些可能遭受失眠等问题困扰的人来说尤其艰难，对吧？他们不断地处于睡眠债务中。失眠是一种睡眠障碍，患者很难入睡或保持睡眠。显然，经历这种情况的人不仅超级沮丧，因为休息是人类必不可少的生物学身体需求。而且这意味着他们正在
between being asleep and being awake in a matter of seconds. but that lapse can kind of be life or death. Our body will start to shut down when we don't sleep and it will force us into a place of unconsciousness because it desperately needs time to build back up those energy stores, to restore cells and neural connections and to just be a functioning organism. So this kind of brings me to the infamous Russian sleep experiment. Now, this sleep experiment is very famous, very well known, I think, but it's also probably not true. It probably didn't happen.
增加他们的情感敏感性。他们更有可能经历较差的集中力、易怒。它甚至会增加我们罹患慢性疾病的风险因子，比如糖尿病、高血压、心脏病。我想回去纠正一下自己。并不是说他们选择这样的，对吧？并不是说他们刻意增加了自己的易感性。只是睡眠不足会带来很多次要后果。它甚至会导致幻觉或增加我们所说的微睡眠。因此，如果你最近看过任何道路安全广告牌，我想你会熟悉这个概念，即我们的大脑可以在几秒钟内非常迅速地
Very sorry to burst the bubble of my fellow dark history lovers. But despite that, I do love talking about this urban myth, because whoever came up with it got some things very right about sleep. So if you don't know the story, the story goes that Soviet-era scientists created this stimulant, which they believed would enable soldiers to not require sleep for up to 30 days a month. Let's just pause. Who thinks that that is possible? That's ridiculous.
在睡眠和清醒之间切换。但这种闪失可能是生死攸关的。当我们不睡觉时，我们的身体将开始关闭，并迫使我们进入无意识状态，因为它迫切需要时间来重建这些能量储备，恢复细胞和神经连接，并成为一个正常运作的有机体。这就把我们带到了声名狼藉的俄罗斯睡眠实验。现在，这个睡眠实验非常有名，众所周知，我认为，但它很可能不是真的。它可能没有发生过。
But as the urban myth goes, they tried to test this new gas on five political prisoners that they had. And they promised that these prisoners would go free if they survived. They locked these five men in a little chamber and they started pumping in this stimulant in gas form. Within a few days, the men were exhibiting the kind of paranoia and psychosis that is very typical of sleep deprivation. But as time went on, they began to act even more strangely. And once the scientists went in, they found that a couple of them had died and the remaining of them exhibited very violent behavior, had these strange energy bursts, hallucinations, and then as soon as they did fall asleep, they died. Let's just be clear this did not actually happen because it would be
对于我那些喜欢黑暗历史的同好们，我很抱歉打破你们的幻想。但尽管如此，我依然喜欢谈论这个都市传说，因为无论谁想出这个故事，对睡眠都有一些非常正确的理解。如果你不知道这个故事，故事是这样的：苏联时期的科学家创造了一种兴奋剂，他们认为这种兴奋剂可以让士兵长达30天不需要睡眠。让我们暂停一下。谁会认为这是可能的？这太荒谬了。
physically impossible to stay awake for more than 10 days. Actually, the world record for how long someone has stayed awake was back in the 60s. It was set by this man named Randy Gardner. And I think he only lasted in like, I think it was 600 hours. I don't know. I think it was like, yeah, maybe, I don't know how many days it was. I'll put it in the notes because I think it was around 600 hours. I think it was like 14 days. Hi, this is future Gemma coming back to say it was actually 264 hours. Let's continue. But whilst he was doing that, he experienced some insane behavior and cognitive changes. Now, I will say he was being like heavily supervised by doctors and scientists from Stanford University.
但正如都市传说所说，他们试图在五个政治犯身上测试这种新毒气。他们承诺，如果这些囚犯活下来就会获得自由。他们把这五个男人锁在一个小房间里，开始以气态泵入这种兴奋剂。几天之内，这些男人就表现出了剥夺睡眠非常典型的偏阳和精神病症状。但随着时间的推移，他们开始表现得更加诡异。一旦科学家们进去，他们发现其中几个人已经死了，剩下的人表现出非常暴力的行为、奇怪的精力爆发、幻觉，而且一旦他们真的睡着了，他们就死了。让我们明确一点，这实际上并没有发生，因为
But as time went on, they started asking him to do these small cognitive tests. And each day they hit they would ask him to do the same one. So one of these tests was to start at 100 and subtract 7 until he got to zero. The first few days he could do it, he started to slow down. By the last day, he couldn't make it past 65 before he stopped. And when they asked him, they were like, hey, why did you stop counting? He was like, what are you asking me? What are you telling me?
保持清醒超过10天在生理上是不可能的。事实上，一个人保持清醒的最长世界纪录是在60年代创下的。这个纪录由一个叫兰迪·加德纳（Randy Gardner）的人创下。我想他只坚持了，我觉得大概是600个小时。我不知道。我觉得大概是，是的，我不知道那是多少天。我会把它放在笔记里，因为我觉得大约是600个小时。我觉得大概是14天。嗨，我是未来的杰玛（Gemma），回来补充一下，实际上是264小时。我们继续。但在他这样做的时候，他经历了一些疯狂的行为和认知变化。现在，我要说的是，他受到了来自斯坦福大学的医生和科学家的严密监督。
I don't even know what I meant to be doing right now. He also forgot his name. He forgot his age. He even forgot his race. Randy was Caucasian by the end of this period. He was claiming that he was African American. And he truly believed it. All of this sounds like insane, but it did happen.
但随着时间的推移，他们开始让他做这些小的认知测试。每天他们都会要求他做同一个。因此，其中一项测试是从100开始减去7，直到减到零。前几天他还能做到，他开始变慢了。到了最后一天，他在停止之前甚至过不了65。当他们问他时，他们问：“嘿，你为什么停止计数了？”他就像是：“你在问我什么？你在对我说什么？”
And it's really scary to me to think about how much we can mentally decline because of sleep deprivation. For me, I don't think I can last more than two days. Good job, Brandy. However many days, he did it. It was definitely more than me. When I flew to New York last year, I'm so bad at sleeping on planes, so I was awake for over 24 hours. I couldn't, my eyes couldn't focus.
我甚至不知道我现在应该在做什么。他还忘了自己的名字。他忘了自己的年龄。他甚至忘了自己的种族。兰迪是白人，但在这个时期结束时。他声称自己是非裔美国人。而且他深信不疑。所有这些听起来都很疯狂，但它确实发生了。
I got like a terrible blood nose, the first I've ever had in my life. I was so irritable. I couldn't make sense of my surroundings. I was like, didn't know what I needed to do. Eventually I fell asleep on this couch that I found in a shopping center before I could check into my hotel. So I think that that really highlights the dangers here, right? you know, a couple of days where we get six, seven hours, it's not going to kill you, you will be in sleep debt.
一想到睡眠剥夺会给我们带来多大的精神衰退，我就感到非常害怕。对我来说，我想我坚持不了两天以上。干得好，兰迪。无论他坚持了多少天，绝对比我多。去年我飞往纽约时，我在飞机上睡觉极差，所以我醒了24个多小时。我无法，我的眼睛无法对焦。
But when we consistently pursue sleep deprivation, we are going to see very real physical, emotional, cognitive, and mental consequences. So that's one side of an extreme spectrum, ultimate sleep deprivation from our friend Randy and our Russian friends, maybe, maybe not. But we can also oversleep, which has its own set of health risks. there is a nice sweet spot for how much sleep we should be getting. And like anything, sleep can be used as a form of not self-harm, but self-sabotage. So I want to talk about that after this break as well as kind of getting into the interactions between sleep and mental health. We'll be back in just a second.
我流了可怕的鼻血，这是我一生中第一次。我太易怒了。我无法理清周围的环境。我当时就像，不知道自己需要做什么。最后我在一个购物中心找到的一张沙发上睡着了，甚至在我入住酒店之前。所以我认为这真的凸显了这里的危险，对吧？你知道的，有几天我们只睡六、七个小时，这不会要你的命，你会有睡眠债务。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
但当我们持续追求睡眠剥夺时，我们将看到非常真实的身体、情感、认知和精神后果。这就是极端光谱的一端，来自我们的朋友兰迪和我们的俄罗斯朋友（可能吧，可能不是）的终极睡眠剥夺。但我们也会睡眠过多，这也有其自身的一套健康风险。对于我们应该获得多少睡眠，有一个很好的最佳平衡点。和任何事情一样，睡眠也可以被用作一种自我伤害（或者说自我破坏）的形式。所以我想在这次休息后讨论这一点，并探讨睡眠与心理健康之间的相互作用。我们马上回来。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the reasons. result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little? little Kim, well you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English.
2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上具有炎症性。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS. on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即英文中的 TWO percent，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations
小金，好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back At It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）一起畅谈80年代的快克。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条红线。我们现在还有艾滋病摆在桌面上。
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough.
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长的学问》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域超过十年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
我指的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它，却不知道什么时候已经做得够多了。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring. inconsistencies in her story.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines），在我的新播客《艰难成长的学问》（Learn the Hard Way）中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索《艰难成长的学问》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后举行的家庭法院听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news
这引发了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾多次篡改过这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。这需要一支网络侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The interactions between
格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻
sleep and mental health are A, endless and B, very well documented. They are also multidirectional, meaning that sleep impacts our mental well-being and our mental well-being impacts our sleep. Sleep plays a crucial role in maintaining mental health. It's not to say that it is a cure, more so that just the quality and duration of sleep directly impacts our emotional regulation as we've spoken about, our cognitive functions and our ability to filter through our thought. So research indicates that consistent, insufficient or poor quality sleep can actually contribute to more intense mental health symptoms. This is particularly when it comes to things like depression, anxiety, bipolar disorder. These kinds of conditions seem to really suffer when we have less mental energy, I would say, or less restorative time to a
马里科帕县传来消息，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。睡眠与心理健康之间的相互作用
allow us to function at our best and to manage the ways that our emotions are more complex because of these conditions. Additionally, it's interesting because if you do have one of those mental health conditions, you're also more likely to experience disruptions in sleep patterns. So you're kind of locked into this like terrible cycle. Insomnia was something we spoke about before and insomnia can be a symptom of anxiety. Even depression. Oversleeping can be a sign of the extreme fatigue that we also see with depressive episodes or symptoms. We can also use sleep as a form of self-sabotage. So self-sabotage refers to an intentional action that kind of undermines our ability to
是：A、无休止的，B、有据可查的。它们也是双向的，这意味着睡眠会影响我们的心理健康，而我们的心理健康也会影响我们的睡眠。睡眠在维持心理健康方面发挥着至关重要的作用。这并不是说它是一剂灵药，而是说睡眠的质量和持续时间直接影响我们之前谈到的情绪调节、我们的认知功能以及我们过滤思想的能力。因此，研究表明，持续的、不足的或低质量的睡眠实际上会导致更强烈的心理健康症状。当涉及到抑郁症、焦虑症、双相情感障害等情况时，尤其如此。当我们拥有较少的心理能量，或者说较少能让我们发挥最佳状态、管理因这些病情而变得更复杂的情绪的恢复时间时，这些情况似乎真的会受到影响。
accomplish our goals. Now, these are goals that we want to accomplish. There is just some part of us that maybe doesn't think that we're worthy, that maybe is scared of what would happen if we did, that maybe is procrastinating or getting weighed down by insecurity, perfectionism, self-doubt. When we decide to sleep in, stay in bed, you know, indulge in a dysregulated sleeping habits and sleeping pattern, this might indicate that there are other areas of our life that we are dissatisfied with. And so sleep becomes a way of allowing us to switch off and allowing us to almost get in our own way in a sense.
此外，这很有趣，因为如果你确实患有其中一种心理健康疾病，你也更有可能经历睡眠模式的紊乱。所以你有点被锁在这个可怕的循环中。失眠是我们之前讨论过的事情，失眠可能是焦虑的症状。甚至抑郁症。嗜睡可能是极端疲劳的一个迹象，我们在抑郁发作或症状中也会看到这种极端疲劳。我们还可以将睡眠用作一种自我破坏的形式。因此，自我破坏是指某种削弱我们完成目标能力的故意行为。现在，这些是我们想要完成的目标。只是我们内心深处的某个部分可能认为自己不配，可能害怕如果我们成功了会发生什么，可能在拖延，或者被不安全感、完美主义、自我怀疑所压垮。当我们决定睡懒觉、赖在床上、沉溺于失调的睡眠习惯和睡眠模式时，这可能表明我们生活中的其他领域令我们感到不满。因此，睡眠成了一种让我们切换大脑、在某种程度上让我们作茧自缚的方式。
So basically what I'm trying to say is sleep is a way for us to feel like we're doing something productive, right? We feel like we're resting our body. Sometimes we really do need that if we're burnt out, right? And we have been chasing a goal for a long time. But on the other end of the spectrum, it can also be this way of self-sabotaging, of being almost self-destructive. So if you want a good but non-scientific book about this, there is one that went particularly viral on TikTok recently, and it was called my year of rest and relaxation. I read this
所以基本上我想说的是，睡觉是我们觉得自己在做一些有成效的事情的方式，对吧？我们觉得我们在让身体休息。有时如果我们筋疲力尽，我们确实需要这样，对吧？而且我们一直在追求一个目标很长时间。但在光谱的另一端，它也可能成为一种自我毁灭、近乎自我破坏的方式。如果你想找一本关于这个话题但又不是那么学术的好书，最近TikTok上有一本特别火的书，叫做《我的一年休息和放松》。我读过这本
quite recently. It basically tells the story of this woman. I would say she is a very unlike a boar's protagonist, but she believes that if she sleeps for a whole year, she'll somehow fix everything in her life, but she also believes that she'll be able to ignore her problems. This book is great, and it's not obviously about sleep. It's about the things that happen in the moments that she is awake that contribute to her wanting to rest. But I think that things are a lot easier when we are unconscious, right? No wonder we use sleep as a form of avoidance from the problems that we face when we're awake. There is another concept I want to talk about here called revenge, bedtime, procrastination.
不久前。它基本上讲述了一个女人的故事。我可以说她是一个非常不像传统意义上的主角的人，但她相信如果她能睡上一整年，她就能以某种方式修复生活中的一切，但她也相信她能够忽视自己的问题。这本书很棒，它显然不只是关于睡眠。它是关于在她清醒的时刻所发生的事情，这些事情促使她想要休息。但我觉得当我们失去意识时，事情要容易得多，对吧？难怪我们把睡眠当作一种逃避清醒时所面对问题的方式。这里还有另一个我想谈的概念，叫做“报复性熬夜”。
This is a Chinese concept whereby when we don't have much control, over our daytime life, we refuse to prioritize sleep in order to regain some sense of freedom during those late night hours. So this is actually quite common amongst high schoolers, for example, who have to go to school for a set period of every day, but also people in their 20s and their 30s who are working really long, exhausting corporate jobs, service jobs, sacrificing their personal lives for their careers and for a service to others. And they kind of quote unquote, get back at the system in the evenings to steal some of that personal time. Now, this idea of procrastination makes it sounds like we are doing things we have perhaps put off and doing them when we should be sleeping.
这是一个中国概念，意思是当我们对白天的生活缺乏控制时，为了在深夜找回一些自由感，我们拒绝优先保证睡眠。所以这实际上在高中生中相当普遍，例如，他们每天必须在学校待上一段固定的时间，还有20多岁和30多岁的年轻人，他们做着非常漫长、令人疲惫的公司工作、服务工作，为了职业生涯和服务他人而牺牲个人生活。他们有点像是在傍晚时分向体制“复仇”，以夺回一部分个人时间。现在，这个关于拖延的想法听起来好像我们在做那些可能被搁置的事情，而且应该睡觉的时候却在做。
Not always the case. Sometimes we are just doing things simply for our pleasure and we feel like we need to do them, right? Like rearranging your bookshelf at like 3 a.m. online shopping, cleaning out all your bathroom cabinets spontaneously, doing like an extravagant makeup look before you fall asleep. All of this is taking from our sleep, but it's depositing time back in our leisure bank, which we may be, you know, gravely missing because of how much our waking hours are taken up by work or other responsibilities. It's interesting because this is being reported more and more, especially as studies are showing that around 60% of us are getting less than the recommended 7 to 8 hours. We're averaging about 6 hours at the moment. Averaging means that
并不总是这样。有时我们只是为了快乐而做事情，而且觉得我们必须去做，对吧？比如凌晨3点重新整理书架、网上购物、突击清理所有的浴室橱柜、在入睡前画一个夸张的妆。所有这些都在剥夺我们的睡眠，但它把时间存回了我们的休闲银行里，由于我们的清醒时间被工作或其他责任占据了太多，我们可能非常渴望这些时间。有趣的是，这方面的报道越来越多，特别是研究表明，大约60%的人睡眠时间达不到推荐的7到8小时。我们目前的平均睡眠时间大约是6小时。平均意味着
there are a lot of us who are getting less than that. And the biggest contributors to this lack of sleep that we are enduring as a society are stress, busy work schedules and school schedules, people are spending more time at work, more time studying more time working than ever before, then also things like pollution, noise pollution, sleeping environment and responsibilities that just come with life. You know, our lives are increasingly busy and we are overstretched. We need to juggle work, life, friends, relationships, family, fitness, well-being, eating three meals a day, keeping our houses clean, just keeping up with our. own needs. And I think in a world that is steering more towards the glorification of hustle culture,
我们当中有很多人达不到这个标准。作为社会成员，我们忍受的这种睡眠缺乏，最大的罪魁祸首是压力、繁忙的工作和学校日程。人们花在工作上的时间更多，学习的时间更多，工作的时间比以往任何时候都多，还有污染、噪声污染、睡眠环境以及生活带来的种种责任。你知道的，我们的生活越来越忙碌，我们压力过大。我们需要兼顾工作、生活、朋友、人际关系、家庭、健身、健康、一天吃三顿饭、保持房屋清洁，还要跟上我们自己的需求。我认为在这个越来越趋向于美化奋斗文化的时代，
sleep is seen as a luxury, even sometimes as a point of laziness. This whole narrative that to rest is to not be self-disciplined, to not be committed to your job or to school or to your life, I think it admits a huge part of the narrative, which is that sleep gives life. and rest is truly, truly important for us to restore connections, restore our energy levels, restore ourselves, and actually function optimally. So that brings me to this concept of sleep hygiene and how we can get more from our sleep, how we can avoid those nights when you desperately want some shut-eye like you crave it and you just won't stop tossing and turning.
睡眠被视为一种奢侈品，有时甚至被视为懒惰的表现。这种把休息等同于缺乏自律、对工作、学校或生活缺乏承诺的整体叙事，忽略了叙事中至关重要的一部分，那就是睡眠赋予生命，而休息对于恢复联系、恢复能量水平、恢复自我以及真正实现最佳功能来说，真的是非常、非常重要。这就把我带到了“睡眠卫生”这个概念，以及我们如何能从睡眠中获得更多，如何避开那些你极度渴望闭眼睡觉、内心充满渴望却在床上翻来覆去睡不着觉的夜晚。
our quality of sleep does have a lot to do without choices and behaviours, from consuming caffeine to close to our bedtime, even exercising in the evenings, or reaching a point of exhaustion that is so extreme that our body actually starts to go in the opposite direction. It starts to pump us with adrenaline and cortisol to keep us awake so that when it's time to sleep, we actually like physically can't. But the biggest devil of all of them in the discussion at the moment is our phones. and using our phones before bed.
我们的睡眠质量确实与我们的选择和行为有很大关系，从在临睡前摄入咖啡因，到在晚间运动，或者是精疲力竭到某种极端的程度，以至于我们的身体开始走向相反的方向。它开始向我们体内注入肾上腺素和皮质醇来让我们保持清醒，结果到了该睡觉的时候，我们实际上在生理上根本做不到。但所有这些当中最大的恶魔，目前在讨论中的就是我们的手机，以及在睡前使用手机。
Our phones, social media, websites, whatever you are on, literally floods our brains with information and bright lights, sounds, activity, and of course, as a result, it floods our brains with neurotransmitters which keep our mind active when we want them to be winding down. The reason this happens is because screens emit blue light, which can interfere with our body's natural production, and release of melatonin. Melatonin, of course, is the hormone responsible for regulating our sleep wake cycle. Blue light is particularly bad in this situation because it tricks our brain
我们的手机、社交媒体、网站，无论你在浏览什么，实际上都在用大量的信息、强烈的灯光、声音和活动充斥着我们的大脑，当然，结果就是，它用神经递质充斥着我们的大脑，在我们希望大脑放松的时候让它保持活跃。之所以会这样，是因为屏幕会发射蓝光，这会干扰我们身体对褪黑素的自然产生和释放。当然，褪黑素是负责调节我们睡眠觉醒周期的荷尔蒙。在这种情况下，蓝光尤其糟糕，因为它会欺骗我们的大脑
into thinking that it's still daytime. So we should be awake, we should be alert, we should be ready to go. Exposure to screens before bed suppresses the release of melatonin, so it makes it more difficult to fall asleep, but then it bumps off our sleep wake cycle so we wake. We wake up later as well. So this really disrupts our body's circadian rhythm. It leads to sleep disturbances. It leads to revenge sleep, sleep debt, and it just impacts our overall ability to sustainably function in our lives, in our relationships, in every facet of what we do. So if you want better sleep, your first step is to create a screen-free bedroom or space for yourself. So according to the Sleep Health Foundation, it's really important to actually train your brain
以为现在仍然是白天。所以我们应该保持清醒，我们应该保持警惕，我们应该准备好行动。睡前接触屏幕会抑制褪黑素的释放，因此这会使人更难入睡，但它随后会打乱我们的睡眠觉醒周期，所以我们醒来也会更晚。所以这确实干扰了我们身体的昼夜节律。它会导致睡眠紊乱，导致报复性睡眠、睡眠债务，并且它只是影响了我们在生活、人际关系以及我们所做的方方面面中持续发挥功能的整体能力。所以如果你想要更好的睡眠，你的第一步就是为自己创建一个无屏幕的卧室或空间。因此，根据睡眠健康基金会（Sleep Health Foundation）的说法，真正重要的是训练你的大脑
to link your bed with sleep and sleep only. So if possible, you want to avoid bringing anything into your bedroom that makes you feel like you are not resting. So that doesn't mean that you can't like be on your phone or your laptop in your room. You know, I know a lot of us live in chairhouses or live with our parents and we don't necessarily want to be doing everything that we do on our laptops and our phones and our iPads like in the living room or in the dining room. But try and keep it out of your bed. That is the space you want to associate with rest, not with alertness. So I started doing this recently. Oh my goodness. It's like lights out for me as soon as I'm in my bed because that is a space now that I only use for one activity and that association means
将你的床与睡眠以及仅仅睡眠联系起来。所以如果可能的话，你要避免把任何让你觉得无法休息的东西带进卧室。所以这并不意味着你不能在房间里玩手机或笔记本电脑。你知道，我知道我们很多人住在合租房里或者和父母住在一起，我们不一定想在客厅或餐厅做我们在笔记本电脑、手机和iPad上做的所有事情。但尽量不要把它带到床上。那是你想要联想到休息而不是警惕的空间。所以我最近开始这么做了。天哪。我一上床就立刻关灯，因为那是一个我现在只用于一项活动的太空，这种关联意味着
I'm better able to just switch off. My brain is queued to knowing that this is the time to sleep. If you feel like you hate going from like being immediately on in your life to like immediately off and having to go into bed, turn the lights off and just like lie there and pretend to be asleep before you actually fall asleep, you can present yourself with alternatives. I think reading before bed is amazing, obviously, but also sleep podcasts are a great help. There is one show that does this so well called, what's it called? Okay, it's called Quiet Bedtime Stories and Meditations. And they have this episode called King Kajada. I don't know when I found this show, but, or I found this episode, this episode is amazing, but it honestly lulls me into such, like, peaceful rest.
我能够更好地直接切换状态。我的大脑接收到的信号是，现在是睡觉时间。如果你觉得你讨厌从生活中“时刻在线”的状态直接切换到“立刻关闭”的状态，不得不上床，关上灯，然后就这样躺在那里，在真正入睡前假装自己已经睡着了，你可以为自己提供替代方案。我认为睡前阅读当然很棒，但睡眠播客也是一个巨大的帮助。有一个节目做得非常好，叫什么来着？好的，它叫《安静的睡前故事与冥想》（Quiet Bedtime Stories and Meditations）。他们有一集叫《卡哈达国王》（King Kajada）。我不知道我是什么时候发现这个节目的，或者我发现了这一集，这一集太棒了，但它真的能让我进入那种非常平静的休息状态。
I'm going to be honest, I've never made it pass like the first 10 minutes. And it's a really great thing to add to your routine when you aren't someone who can immediately relax as soon as your head hits the pillow. So let's talk about some other tips. Firstly, I love this one. Create an environment you actually want to be in. One that is cool, one that is dark, one that is quiet, one that is comfortable. I will never understand people who can sleep in like a boiling hot room.
说实话，我从来没有撑过前10分钟。当你不是那种头一沾枕头就能立刻放松下来的人时，这是一个非常棒的习惯补充。所以我们来聊聊其他一些小建议。首先，我非常喜欢这个：创造一个你真正想身处其中的环境。一个凉爽、黑暗、安静且舒适的环境。我永远不会理解那些能在热得沸腾的房间里睡觉的人。
You know, I need it to be like 15 degrees Celsius in order for me to fall asleep. I like to have one too many blankets. I like to cocoon myself into like a little burrito. It also really makes the difference to like get nice bed sheets because you want your brain to be like, this is a comforting, cozy, peaceful space. I enjoy being here. You know, your stained white bed sheets from your first year of uni, which are like weirdly itchy. They might be the economic choice, but I don't think they're conducive to restfulness.
你知道，我需要大约15摄氏度才能入睡。我喜欢盖不止一条毯子。我喜欢把自己像一个小卷饼一样包裹起来。买好的床单也真的能带来改变，因为你会希望你的大脑觉得：这是一个令人欣慰、舒适、平静的空间。我很享受待在这里。你知道的，你大一时的那些洗得发白、摸起来怪怪的、痒痒的床单。它们可能是经济的选择，但我觉得它们不利于休息。
This is such like an adult thing to say. honestly, I think I turned 24 and I immediately had like a sheep preference and a mattress preference. And now, if I'm on a firm mattress, it's not happening. You know, I get it. It's really giving princess in the pee. But honestly, sleep is an investment. And as is your mattress, your memory foam pillow, your cotton sheets. My mom always said like sleep is not about being cheap and I didn't really understand that when I was younger and broke. But now I do.
这真的是很成熟的一句话。说实话，我想我到了24岁时，立刻就对床单和床垫有了偏好。现在，如果让我睡硬床垫，那是绝对不行的。你知道的，我懂的。这真的很像“豌豆公主”。但说实话，睡眠是一项投资。床垫、记忆棉枕头、纯棉床单也是如此。我妈妈总是说，睡觉不能省钱，自我年轻时身无分文的时候，我其实并不理解这一点。但现在我懂了。
and it doesn't mean that you need to spend like an insane amount of money that is out of your budget. You can get secondhand really good mattresses. You can find really good sheets that are on sale. I just think it's an important thing. You'll have it for a long time. And it will contribute to you just feeling more alive in your waking life. So also try and be consistent with your sleep schedule. I know this is really hard, especially in our 20s.
这并不意味着你需要花一大笔超出你预算的疯狂金额。你可以买到二手的、非常好的床垫。你可以找到正在打折的非常好的床单。我只是觉得这是一件重要的事情。你会用它很长时间。它将有助于你在清醒的生活中感觉更有活力。所以还要尽量保持睡眠时间表的一致性。我知道这真的很难，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候。
but at least doing it during the week is important. Your body's circadian rhythm functions, they're set on a loop. And typically they align with sunrise and sunset or when you tell your body to switch off and then seven, eight hours after that point. Being consistent with when you fall asleep during the week, even on weekends, if you can, helps kind of train your brain into being like, all right, this is the time when we switch off. Same time, every day, no surprises. It's really very valuable. There was a study published in the National Library of Medicine from 2009. It highlights that irregular sleep patterns can alter our levels of melatonin.
但至少在工作日这样做是很重要的。你身体的昼夜节律功能是设定在一个循环中的。通常它们与日出和日落相吻合，或者与你告诉身体关闭的时间相吻合，在那之后再过七、八个小时。在工作日保持入睡时间的一致性，如果可以的话，甚至在周末也保持一致，有助于训练你的大脑，让它觉得：好吧，这就是我们关闭系统的时间。每天同一时间，没有意外。这真的非常宝贵。美国国家医学图书馆（National Library of Medicine）在2009年发表过一项研究。它强调，不规律的睡眠模式会改变我们体内的褪黑素水平。
It can alter the signals that are telling our brain to sleep. And what that will mean is that no matter how hard you try, you're not going to get to sleep unless your melatonin has been released and is present in your body because you can't physically shut down. you can take a supplement, but you can also produce it naturally. So I think it may just be the case that your melatonin release is being delayed by poor sleep habits and routine, and you can get back onto a normal sleep routine by remaining consistent. So even if you get to bed by nine, I'm nine so early, maybe it's not for some of you, let's say 10, put it in even 10.
它会改变向大脑发出睡眠信号的指令。这意味着，无论你多么努力，除非你的褪黑素已经释放并存在于你的体内，否则你是无法入睡的，因为你在生理上无法关闭系统。你可以服用补充剂，但你也可以自然产生它。所以这可能只是因为不良的睡眠习惯和作息推迟了你的褪黑素释放，而你可以通过保持规律来恢复到正常的睡眠作息。所以即使你在9点上床——9点太早了，也许对你们中的一些人来说不是，假设是10点吧，哪怕定在10点。
You're in bed by 10, but you find yourself like tossing and turning till 12. good. Stay in bed. Don't go on your phone. Sooner or later, your body is going to get trained to be like, no. This is our bedtime now. This is when we're hitting the hay. On that note, try and expose yourself to sunlight or the outdoors immediately after waking, normally within the first hour, because again, this is going to help your body clock switch off production of melatonin and reset you to a regular pattern. You know, humans are meant to be outdoor creatures, not indoor creatures. We used to live our lives and our waking hours by the sun until Thomas Edison invented the light bulb. No, just kidding.
你10点上床，但发现自己翻来覆去直到12点。没关系。待在床上。不要玩手机。迟早你的身体会被训练得觉得：不。这就是我们的睡觉时间。这就是我们该上床睡觉的时候。顺便说一句，尽量在醒来后立即接触阳光或户外空气，通常在第一个小时内，因为同样，这将有助于你的身体生物钟关闭褪黑素的生产，并让你恢复到一个规律的模式。你知道，人类注定是户外生物，而不是室内生物。在托马斯·爱迪生发明电灯泡之前，我们的生活和清醒时间都是顺应太阳的。不，开玩笑的。
Like, in all seriousness, I think the best way to do anything for your health is to do it the way that has been done for generations and generations, meaning that the best way to get quality sleep is to align your body to how evolutionarily and biologically you were kind of evolving and developed to seek rest. I think it comes a lot easier when we do that. Another tip, exercise more, but try not to do anything intense before bed. I think it's a double-edged sword. Exercise obviously increases exhaustion, but it also, you know, means that our bodies kind of are flooded with a lot of activity, a lot of adrenaline,
认真地说，我认为为健康做任何事情的最好方法，就是以世世代代流传下来的方式去做，这意味着获得优质睡眠的最佳方法，是让你的身体顺应演化和生物学上你被培育和发展来寻求休息的方式。当我们这样做时，事情会变得容易得多。另一个建议，多运动，但尽量不要在睡前做任何剧烈运动。我认为这是一把双刃剑。运动显然会增加疲劳感，但它也意味着我们的身体会充斥着大量的活动、大量的肾上腺素、
norapinephrine, a lot of dopamine that can keep us awake for longer. Now, there has been studies into this, and there was one by Harvard Health published a few years back, and your average evening workout is not going to hurt you too much. But if you're doing a full-on heavy cardio, hit workout, burning hundreds, thousands of calories an hour, like 30 minutes before bed, coming home, showering and expecting yourself to fall asleep, I don't think that you're going to get to that level of deep sleep that we need for restoration any quicker. So it's important to make exercise a component to, you know, actually use the energy stores that your body wants you to use throughout the day. But try not to
去甲肾上腺素、大量的多巴胺，这些会让我们保持更长时间的清醒。现在，已经有关于这方面的研究了，几年前哈佛健康（Harvard Health）发表过一项研究，你平常的晚间锻炼不会对你造成太大伤害。但如果你在睡前大约30分钟进行一次全面、高强度的有氧运动、HIIT（高强度间歇训练），每小时燃烧几百、上千卡热量，回家洗个澡就期望自己能睡着，我认为你是无法更快达到恢复所需的深度睡眠水平的。所以，把运动作为消耗身体整天想要消耗的能量储备的一个组成部分是很重要的，但尽量不要
do it too close to when you really want to like be asleep, be dreaming, be counting sheep. Final tip, try and avoid alcohol. I know that alcohol helps us fall asleep quicker. So if you are someone who is dealing with insomnia, there is a huge urge to just like have a nightcap. But alcohol is an inhibitor or a downer. That's what causes us to feel sleepy because it increases GABA, which slows down the specific signals in our central nervous system.
在距离你真正想睡觉、做梦、数羊的时间太近的时候进行。最后的建议，尽量避免饮酒。我知道酒精能帮助我们更快入睡。所以如果你是一个正在应对失眠的人，就会有一种巨大的冲动想要喝一杯睡前酒。但酒精是一种抑制剂或镇静剂。这就是让我们感到困倦的原因，因为它增加了GABA（γ-氨基丁酸），从而减缓了中枢神经系统中的特定信号。
But as the alcohol is metabolized and processed, it causes an additional spike in glutamate. Now glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter. So your brain is basically switching back on as the alcohol wears off at like 3, 4 a.m. in the morning. This may be why you might notice like after a heavy night of drinking, all you want to do is have a sleep in and you're waking up at 7 a.m. Kind of like cursing the sun.
但随着酒精被代谢和处理，它会导致谷氨酸额外激增。现在谷氨酸是一种兴奋性神经递质。所以当酒精在凌晨3、4点左右消退时，你的大脑基本上会重新开启。这可能就是为什么你可能会注意到，在经历了一个晚上的大饮之后，你唯一想做的事情就是睡个懒觉，然后在早上7点醒来。有点像是在诅咒太阳。
Can't get back asleep. It's because your brain is trying to level out the gabber that it received. from processing and metabolizing alcohol by spiking the glutamate to get that balance back to kind of a nice homeo point of homeostase as a point of normalcy. Alcohol, caffeine, nicotine, those are our big sleep. No-noes. I also just want to say, don't get too caught up and worrying about when you'll fall asleep. Just stay kind of focused on being present in your body and relaxing.
无法重新入睡。这是因为你的大脑正试图通过激增谷氨酸来抵消它从处理和代谢酒精中获得的GABA，以恢复这种平衡，达到一个完美的稳态点，一个正常点。酒精、咖啡因、尼古丁，这些都是我们睡眠的“大忌”。我还想说的是，不要太陷入对何时能入睡的担忧中。只需专注于当下身体的存在和放松。
I know it can be stressful. And yes, I've spoken a lot about the harms of not getting a good night's sleep. Don't let that become an anxiety for you. Don't let that become a point of fixation. Your body will do what it needs to do naturally unless you do have a sleep disorder. So if you are consistently experiencing terrible sleep, you're waking up in the middle of the night, that is your opportunity to go and see a doctor. But eventually you will fall asleep.
我知道这会带来压力。是的，我谈了很多睡眠不足的危害。不要让这成为你的焦虑。不要让这成为一个执念。你的身体会自然地做它需要做的事情，除非你确实患有睡眠障碍。所以如果你持续经历糟糕的睡眠，半夜醒来，那正是你去看医生的契机。但最终你会入睡的。
Eventually your eyes will close. eventually your brain will shut down. We spoke about those experiments before, right? Our bodies cannot stay alert and functioning at all hours of the day. So it's going to do what it needs to do biologically and evolutionarily and just like forward survival and it will make you fall asleep. There's no need to stress. There's no need to stress.
最终你的眼睛会闭上。最终你的大脑会关闭。我们之前谈过那些实验，对吧？我们的身体无法在一天中的所有时间都保持警惕和运转。所以它会按照生物学和演化以及生存的需要去做，它会让你入睡。没有必要感到压力。没有必要感到压力。
You're going to be okay. You cannot stay awake forever. I promise. I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. It's a bit different. It was science heavy, but we've never spoken about it before, so I thought it deserved a spot on the podcast feed. If you want to come back and listen. If you want to check out our episode on Dreams, it's literally the psychology of dreams by the psychology of your 20s.
你会没事的。你不可能永远保持清醒。我保证。我真心希望你们喜欢这一期节目。它有点不同。它有很多科学内容，但我们以前从未讨论过这个话题，所以我觉得它值得在播客列表中占有一席之地。如果你想回来收听。如果你想查看我们关于梦想的那一期节目，它实际上就是20多岁心理学（The Psychology of your 20s）的“梦想心理学”。
It's a great companion episode to this one. Again, one of my favorite episodes that we've ever done. Make sure that you share this with someone who you think might need it. We all have that friend who's up till 3 a.m. and then is up again at 7 a.m. Don't shame them, but maybe give them a little nudge in the sleepiness direction. If you want to see more behind the scenes, you want to follow along with the podcast, follow along with me, you can follow us at that psychology podcast.
它是这一集的绝佳配套节目。再次强调，这是我们做过的最喜欢的节目之一。确保把它分享给你认为可能需要它的人。我们都有那种直到凌晨3点还在熬夜，然后早上7点又醒来的朋友。不要羞辱他们，但也许可以朝爱睡觉的方向推他们一把。如果你想看到更多幕后花絮，想关注这个播客，关注我，你可以在那个心理学播客（that psychology podcast）关注我们。
You can also send episode suggestions over there. We read every single one, even if we can't get back to you, and we definitely take on board your suggestions. I love seeing our community grow over there. So get in touch, say hi. we would love to see you. Make sure you're following along on Spotify or Apple Codcast, wherever you are listening right now.
你也可以把节目建议发到那边。我们每一条都会读，即使我们无法回复你，我们也绝对会采纳你们的建议。我很高兴看到我们的社区在那里成长。所以请联系我们，打个招呼。我们很乐意看到你。确保在Spotify或Apple Podcast上关注我们，无论你现在在哪里收听。
And give us a five-star review if you're feeling it. If you're feeling especially generous. All right. We're going to head off, but until next time, sleep tight and be kind and gentle with yourselves. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
如果你有这种感觉，请给我们一个五星好评。如果你觉得特别慷慨的话。好了。我们要结束了，但在下次见面之前，祝你好梦，对你自己好一点，温柔一点。嘿，各位好！欢迎收听《艰难中学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难中学习》。
In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hope. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱之陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcast或任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。你获取播客的渠道。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了精神的科学。
toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用上的TWO.%。Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcast或任何地方收听播客。这是一个IHeart播客，保证是真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来发表评论。